i am so excited to introduce our first
guests um they are two brothers who grew
up on the small screen
and then went to the big screen
they have this
extraordinary new book that i can't
recommend
more and it's called the boys a memoir
of hollywood and family
they need no introduction that is for
sure it's ron and clint howard
[Applause]
and your show's great and uh well you're
so talented you're so talented
you know
you talk about in front of them behind
the camera you've done all that stuff
and now this and and uh winning at this
how about that i fell so in love with
your family
reading this book i mean
can you talk to me about your dad's
process
teaching you guys acting because i found
it one of the most poignant things
that's going to change my perspective on
any child's performance he trusted
that even at an early age a kid could
understand the game
of sort of being a part of something
like this on on multiple levels so we
knew it wasn't real he showed us all of
the tricks but then there's this other
thing magic meets
truth and that's what makes the story
and for us as actors he taught us to
sort of build a bridge from sort of what
we understood our logic and what the
story was about and the logic of that
basically it's very simple
actors studio stuff
how do you think that your parents
balanced like
normalcy well
boy you know both mom and dad came from
the midwest and they had this simple
it was it was about the work it was
never about fame and fortune and
notoriety
mom and dad were not interested in that
and for us it was about this is what we
were we were little actors
and we were prepared that's one thing
that dad insisted on and he did it in a
loving way but boy ron and i were both
the most prepared actors when we stepped
onto which gave us so much confidence
you know the other thing is
that
they
later i talked to my dad i said dad
after we were grown
everybody knows how you guided clint and
i so
you know why don't why don't you do this
why don't you start a school why don't
you t why don't you share your your
methodology he said i'm acting i'm
working i did that because i'm your dad
i didn't do it to be sort of the manager
of a couple of kid actors that wasn't it
at all i did it because i thought you
could learn something and whether you
carried on as actors or not i felt like
you could learn how to succeed
and how to have that kind of discipline
and you'd use that in any walk of life
that you would choose and we're the
beneficiaries of that i really feel like
i have such a beautiful sense of your
family
and for anyone who gets to read this
book and go on that journey it is so
powerful so positive
and um i thank you for allowing us in on
this amazing journey it also is filled
with so much infamous history
um of entertainment that i'm sure we all
put ourselves in i mean your movies and
television shows have colored all of our
lives i'm just looking at you guys as
two humans but it what you guys ended up
producing
you know through your work is
life-changing for all of us so i'm going
to throw it to alice um you have a
question um for uh ron and clint yes our
beautiful co-host yes alice and alicia
my sister and i work together
and
um
has it ever been difficult mixing
family and work
and if how does how do you work that out
what's it like when i'm directing you in
a in a in a movie well
i learned my lesson early on
[Laughter]
i was in my probably early twenties and
and yet i had to learn that you know
ultimately
he's the boss he's making the decisions
and it was specifically on cocoon i
remember specifically on cocoon ron sort
of said you know i'm making this call
you know and
listen through dad
i understood you know that there's first
of all i love my brother he's a great
older brother he's a hall of fame movie
director he's a much
[Applause]
he's a better big brother than he is a
movie director oh my god then he must be
the best big brother
well i'll tell you so so the lessons
learned i love the collaboration one
thing is we have an ability to
communicate that doesn't really involve
speaking to each other i'm sure you guys
understand that yeah and i when i when i
do have the opportunity to direct clint
it's always a joy because by the way
he's highly professional he can do just
about anything he's very flexible he's
additive he's creative all these things
that you want but he also will tell me
the truth and he's smart about films and
and he knows what i'm looking for and i
trust his taste so he's additive in a
lot of ways
[Music]
you